what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting
to um flight reacts baby mama drama
um okay i had a hard time finding like
original videos
of him like from his page so i think he
took him down so i'm gonna be reacting
to other reaction accounts um
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily
videos i'm also trying to hit 20 000
subscribers guys bring the notification
bell
while you're at it okay so i just pulled
up
all these different videos that have me
extremely confused
but i'm gonna try to go in like order of
them so it looks like this drama started
back
in october so i'm gonna play this
okay oh and uh you know not you know
letting everything
everybody know what's up and everything
um you know
but i feel like this is rightfully made
uh needs to be made uh
you know what i'm saying because it's
also gonna help you know what i'm saying
officially uh
how can i say like dead everything out
uh when it comes to just like any
there wasn't even honestly no like beef
like except for one i'd never be
i'm not beef never beef with no female
you know see that's just like number one
you know what i'm saying
and then two you're clearly literally
beefing with your a female
if all everyone's talking about this
like what do you mean it's just like at
the end of the day
she is the mother of my child she's my
baby mama you know i'm saying something
i'm gonna have to deal with you know
what i'm saying so it's just at the end
of the day too it also happened
uh thanks you know i'm saying uh god and
you know everything you know i'm saying
it went down
uh no longer gonna be on that uh child
support
uh and you know we i came to an
agreement with the 50 50 thing
um so you know i'm saying with that
being alone and alongside with that you
know i wanted to also
uh react to this because with just what
you guys have been spamming me like
non-stop and
you know i'm a flight reaction you know
what i'm saying where i just like videos
obviously
you know what i'm saying about us uh did
who started this let me know in the
comments i think
she did because he's reacting to her
video
get me a couple of days uh reacts would
be honest with y'all one because i
needed a
cut i needed mine you know i'm saying
face to be cleared up i looked like a
straight bum
and i'm not about to let y'all be
tortured for almost
40 plus minutes and just looking at
somebody like that you know
so i had to get revamped you know what
i'm saying got the you know polo down
you know what i'm saying fresh fit you
know what i'm saying waze is under the
dewey
you know what i'm saying if you want to
see the 360 you're gonna have to look at
so fresh so clean clean
hey hey you skipped this certain part
are you sure you're trying to avoid it
you're being
you're being slick you see that all you
do is just have to sit there and watch
people's video
we're gonna watch everything and you
need enough talking let's get it
so i'ma just keep this
i was trying to skip over i didn't know
if the stuff is copywriter this week
so i'ma just keep this video raw
plain and straightforward and
i just want to talk about a few things
that i just want to get off my chest
um i really actually
didn't want to make this video and i
didn't think about making this video
and i haven't done like this video
because
i felt like i had to sit back and think
about a couple things real quick and
let my mind just be at like ease for a
second and
you know just before i react to things
in a way where i'm gonna come off like
not saying the right things and being
you know
saying things out of anger or being
angry about about certain situations
i rather just stay quiet and
let time heal my mind and then just come
to the internet and
let you guys know what it is give me a
second
excuse me so for one and for most
i feel like one of the reasons why i
wasn't even gonna make this video was
because
i feel like i personally don't owe an
apology to nobody
but my daughter for one and two
uh the father my daughter kamani
i feel like those are the only two
people i want to apologize to
including my family um
my friends his family his friends
and you know i understand that there's
his fans that you know right for him and
are hurt by the situation as well so you
know i guess i give my apologies to all
of you guys
um i do want to say that
you know it's a lot of misconceptions
throughout this whole situation going on
and i feel like people will never
understand it
um if you're not living the life we live
you know and behind cameras you will
never understand
but to keep it plain and simple and
short um
like i said i just wanna i just owe a
bigger pot
morning star farms what
made from plants it's my daughter
um you know i feel like things
could have gone a different route
a better out and more smarter than than
what it was
um i feel like
me being a mother now has made me
think different you know try to be
different and
also think for my daughter not just for
me at the end of the day it's not just
me no more it's my daughter
i'm having a family it's a family like
there's nothing
there's nothing that should be between
us but respect and love
and i feel like i owe it to her to my
daughter because it's like oh my god
lady get to the point you know i don't
want her to be born and just know that
there's a lot of toxic stuff going on
there's a lot of
he said she said or this and that
and for the most part like that's my
everything so at the end of the day like
i don't want her to just grow up and you
know be mentally and like
just messed up because people are coming
for her or people are coming for her
parents and this and that so
it's not gonna happen i'm not nobody's
gonna come at her with that it's just
gonna be on
it's no one's fault
i'm with you flight get to the point
lady so
um also i want to apologize to you
kamani i know you're watching this
um
girl you got his number it does not seem
genuine if you're doing it like
for youtube
and i'm not like emotional like that
y'all i don't want you guys
i want you guys to um
feel bad for me because at the end of
the day i'm just happy knowing that my
daughter
is you know coming soon i'm just more so
like
how do i say it i'm more so like
performing i'm not gonna pause the video
too much because it's just
really hearing things out and just you
know like i said this is a true video
this isn't any type of bashing video
whatsoever and
at all but it's just making things just
correct but it's just like
please stop using our kid for every
single sentence like just please get on
to the point
like daughter that's all but other than
that
anything else is like you know
my my daughter is my biggest priority
right now so that's all that matters to
me
um also you know just me be me and her
me and my daughter just having our
family good and just in good terms
that's all that matters to me at this
point
but let me take it back to kamani
i'm sorry and i want to apologize to you
for
everything that i've put you through
um
how do i say this like
i'm just sorry because like to be honest
with you
y'all y'all gotta understand i'm
pregnant so regardless i'm emotional but
don't like i said don't feel bad for me
i'm good but it's just like
why does she keep saying don't feel bad
for me lady i'm not
get to the point certain topics is i got
down like
here goes prank and janet
but kamani i feel like i'm sorry again
to you and
i'll most for the most part my apologies
to you and you only
and that's because you know it's a lot
of things that have gone behind cameras
that people don't know about
and i feel like i should have taken
things
to like in a different route and be the
smarter and bigger person and instead of
being petty
and trying to get back at you and you
know trying to make you
like get out of your character if
i should say it's too late too late i
feel like
too many chances i must admit
i don't think you can really make
someone act out of their character
i changed a lot and i feel like it's not
only in a good way but in a bad way
um i can admit that
how do i say this i'm not trying to put
the blame on anything or nothing
like or anyone but by myself but at the
end of the day
okay you're not not really it's like
i mean you mean you know what we both
have gone through and i feel like most
of it has affected me
like i said in a good way in a bad way
um
it's no one business but me and you at
the end of the day that's why i feel
like i never should have came out and
done a video just bashing you
everybody knows like whoever knows me at
heart knows that i'm not the type to
bash nobody i'm not the type to bring
nobody down
no matter how peop how much people can
hurt me
okay so she started it she did the video
starting with the whole
bashing okay i feel like
all that stuff just in the past of being
like even petty towards somebody
and trying to get them back i feel like
this time
i didn't really come to the internet and
try to even do a video and getting you
back or anything like that i just suck
it all in
and let people come for me and this and
that but i may say that me going on live
and trying to bring up the situation and
just
try to make fun of it and you know try
to say that
um that you know you're just
maybe the things i said on online
whoever saw it
i'm gonna pause it and go see what the
live was
because i think i this is one of the
videos i pulled up
so okay
i didn't move on i haven't even moved on
i have not even done [ __ ]
like that's what you guys don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey
okay this type of girl
fellas you really should stay away from
like you can just tell
that she's very much into the validation
and the attention like she's clearly had
her lips done
clearly at work done on her face
and facts if you guys think we were
never together why do you guys care what
i do
so [ __ ] we were never together why does
it matter what the [ __ ] i do
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dick riders
it's funny how nobody likes flight
everybody trolls him but when i do some
[ __ ] it's like y'all look like
a [ __ ] yes
[Music]
he tried to record it
cheers
okay so i'm getting a little confused
because they're saying tell your side so
it sounds like he put out the first
video
i'm so confused
let me ask you a question why when a
girl cheats
if she's a hoe but when a [ __ ] cheats
oh
it's whatever he got so much
i could tell you why it's because women
have to have an emotional connection and
men don't
um i don't think it's okay for either
and i think a lot of girls get irritated
because
it just seems like guys can cheat on
them again and again again that's okay
and like what are they supposed to do
according to the manosphere they're
supposed to stay
pretty much no matter what as long as he
doesn't bring home what stds or another
kid
but no i don't think people should cheat
okay and if we're not together why does
it matter what
what we do so don't say don't
like what please someone tell me because
i [ __ ]
everybody the [ __ ] side or the whole
side right
yeah like so yeah she said no
so pretty much all right now look
so why wouldn't a girl cheat she's a hoe
but when the [ __ ] chooses the whole
first of all i'm not cheating because
it ain't even like you guys are together
you feel me but i'm a bad person
type [ __ ] for like i just do it like
i think i think it look honestly
nobody's nobody's [ __ ] while i'm
pregnant that's what he
thinks like flight isn't secure that
whole double speed flight is
highest trust issue since day one
it's just you know what i don't look at
it that way
you know what i'm saying hey i don't
know
the streets you tell me
[Laughter]
hurt wait why is he hurt what's wrong
he's hurt and mad because i moved on
like i'm not even moved on i just don't
want to like be around him who is gonna
put themselves out there like that like
be like oh
hickeys huh there you go like look
at me in that situation like
like if i was such a bad person if i was
psychopath i was crazy if i was a whole
this and that
why didn't he make a video a long time
ago why
why'd he wait so i told him i'ma move on
for him to do a video
because he's hurt he's hurt oh so he did
it i'm so confused where's that video
oh my gosh let me know in the comments
anyone will say anything to be heard
don't entertain that it's not nothing
but a baby daddy
he's nothing but a baby daddy
clown bro
don't even get there i could have ended
a motherfucker's career so
like a long time ago but my heart's so
big
hey kevin look bigger
i know
[Music]
[Music]
um
oh it's like it has a bear yeah that's
those
you ready huh
so is that it
because i don't think that's that bad
okay let's let's keep going you've
probably seen it come on you like
i should have never said the things i
said i should have never tried to even
make fun of it
i should have never just you know just
to make fun of how you actually came
off and and about your feelings because
no matter what everybody has a heart
and everybody you know has love for
somebody at the end of the day
and i understand that you know
i like i said i have changed a lot
my character the way i move the way i
say
things you know and that shouldn't have
been how i should have
went about with things and i feel like
for one like i said
i didn't honestly i didn't catch myself
you know turning into this
person that i that i'm not because you
know i
you when someone gets so caught up in
themselves and being in love with
somebody
just loving somebody you don't see what
you're doing you don't see your
reactions till like you hit rock bottom
with that person so with that being said
like
honestly i could say like i miss
here goes my pride i put that thing
aside
i do miss being the old janet
um what
i miss being like how can i say this i'm
just being nice
to why
why am i sweaty well i do miss being
nice to you come on
honestly i do miss doing
nice things for you like i used to you
know it's just a lot of things that like
i said had
changed me into the way i am now because
of the things we've been through
and like i said it's no one business but
ours like i said
even on live i think most of you seen
how i had said like
oh just being petty like if i wanted to
you know i could have ruined his career
like he's just jealous he's just
insecure he's just this and that
honestly that's not the way to go about
things and to be honest with y'all like
i just i would never try to really do
much to it like even mess up
anyone's career or downplay them or
anything like that because like i said
that's not my character
me and fly like i mean you show me
different
you know i'm saying that's what the
situation you know i'm saying in and out
you know what i'm saying i feel like if
i wasn't to come out and
respectfully and honestly yeah i did my
video about the sad truth video you know
i'm saying months down the road okay
this is the sad
truth video let me look this up
the sad truth okay the sad
truth video flight
reacts
oh so this is what started it
okay
oh my god an hour video stop
oh god
okay so he started it i think i'm gonna
dive straight on to it
you know what i'm saying i'm not trying
to you know beat around the bush jibber
jabber this and that bro
um i just want to make sure first off
and formal before i continue
um and this is towards everybody um make
sure
who you recognize and who you realize
who is close
to you and who is in your circle and who
is in your circle
currently over time and what i mean by
over time it's just
they always say that close people always
hurt you you know what i'm saying you
always need to pay attention
that's pretty much the entire situation
bro
um it's crazy because it was like a a
santa claus wish list bro
of just like [ __ ] that i could like so
like say
and people would just be like damn
flight like
how did you even like hold yourself
together but
this these couple of things were like
the key things to what made me make this
decision
now i honestly had a hundred and five
percent different video
planned for you guys today um
because it was already ready i'm gonna
i'll tell you i had a couple of places
uh and i had went behind the scenes and
i didn't like like him at all
um so you know i kind of narrowed
everything i wanted down into my
decision
and i'm pretty much going to uh you know
find it so fresh so clean clean
uh beautiful house with all the houses
for one i was already single
um what i was doing since she was
pregnant i was trying my hardest to work
things out um also get out into a mental
vacay break um
for a couple reasons you guys um it just
hurts me to like say this but
i feel like and the reason like i just
don't like to make videos like this you
guys like i just don't like i'm just
like
i'm gonna be honest i just like to wake
up
and i'm gonna be honest flight
i've seen too many videos like this to
believe
that you don't like making videos like
this i'm just
i'm just being honest here and just just
have fun and just share you guys my life
your or whatever i'm doing
or you know watching or you know
music or streaming or whatever and just
display entertainment to you guys and
you know what i'm saying
and then go home you know i just want to
make people happy and just make them
forget about the outside life but
i feel like i have a right to sit up
here and you know voice my voice because
i remember when i did a video like this
similar to when i was
out with my ex
i don't like to make videos like this
but
stop stop and then five minutes later
but the last time i made a video like
this and now because this is back in
october
so three months later you're doing the
same [ __ ]
basically um felt like i was free and so
this is the type of videos it's just you
know
um so guys i just want you to
look me right now in my eyes and just
respectfully just like
accept that um for one i was already
single um what i was doing since she was
pregnant i was trying my hardest to work
things out
um with you guys know my baby mama janet
we was i was trying so hard to work
things out uh make things work
these past months and honestly like it's
just been nothing but hell
she's been putting me through nothing
but hell honestly she's been pregnant
honestly even before it you know what
i'm saying like
like i said i have a bigger santa claus
list but i feel like going into the main
points which really made me you know
what i'm saying be like okay this is
just confirmation like
you know what i'm saying like i'm not
being brought down no more you know what
i'm saying
um she just it was so hard to start
where to begin because it's like a list
of stuff
but it's just ever since she's been
pregnant i just
literally seen a different side to her
and the crazy thing is
that i've seen certain red flags like
this before she was even pregnant
but i would ignore them you know what
i'm saying it's just my stubbornness
sometimes and me
working things out and accepting
people's apologies wanting to come back
yeah man you're a good person flight
that's what happens to people like us
man you know you try to get people to
bend for the doubt
you know and when you don't know better
it gets you [ __ ] up
it's happened to me how old is flight
how how old is he when it goes
plenty of times you know y'all singing
aquaforce
shall i bring up the lights king demon
okay he's 25. you can't really say you
don't know better when you're 25 years
old
you know it's one thing when you're like
i think 18 to 21 but after 21 you've had
some dating experience usually
we've already gone down that man this is
about flight
i understand what he's saying that's a
fact fight
that's a [ __ ] fact man and you're not
a bad person because of that fight
you're not a stupid person that
you know you were just you're just a
very nice kind heart person you wanted
to get people benefited out you wanted
to make things work for your baby wanted
to do things for the greater good
still didn't work out you know
you are what you attract
if you constantly find yourself in toxic
relationships
ask yourself why that's all that is
but you know that you know what i'm
saying um but
and you know what's crazy it's always
the same it's like i see this from the
guys right they'll be like
oh i'm so giving i did everything for
her
and she just did this this this and this
and usually there's more to the story
i mean i haven't really gotten into this
too much but usually there's more to the
story
or maybe he possibly has some toxic
traits
that attracts toxic people but you have
to
you have to realize you're not you're
not a victim most of the time
she i just guys i can't i can't do it
anymore like with her so i just want you
guys to respectfully
realize like if you see me out you know
what i'm saying um you know moving on
dating
you know just don't be like oh flight's
out here cheating and doing it wrong and
everything like that
i'm gonna explain what made me get to
this point now
me and janet we've known each other for
two years we've never made it official
i've never made a official i've never
given no promise right never looked
in the face you got down on me and told
you told her to be my girlfriend
you know i'm saying we was just cool and
you know it was just she just happened
to get pregnant you know i'm saying she
was just honestly like the main girl
you know what i'm saying i was messing
with can you feel me and that's just the
bold honest truth i'm pretty sure a lot
of people that had like some type of
iq they could have really told you know
you could tell you know what i'm saying
but anyway you know what i'm saying she
was really just a girl i was just
messing with
what i'm saying when i moved out just
you know so just like a cool vibe you
feel me and it was cool for like the
first six months
you know i'm saying when we first met
but then just started turning left you
know what i'm saying from little things
like
she's just very manipulative she's uh
she hits
uh i just i don't want to say abusive
because i feel like when you call it
girl abusive like it's kind of like
weak because you know i'm a man but it's
just like she does
all that type of ish um she takes my
phone for no reason like she has control
mind you like i have never taken her
phone i don't do that because i don't
want people doing that to me
you know what i'm sorry um she sits
there and sets different
rules down and stuff and i know you know
people are going to go ahead and be like
oh so how are you going to let a girl
run you know
a relationship or you know i'm saying
just run you around like that
you know because i didn't want to say
relationship you never was so i didn't
want you all to take me out of context
but you guys do what i'm saying like
it's just it normally just ends up
and i don't mean for it to happen but it
just happened you feel me like she i let
her get away with a couple things you
know what i'm saying because like i'm
like the bigger person sometimes i look
at things sometimes it's just like
bro i can literally just like agree it
out with this situation
instead of dragging on you know what i'm
saying i just got a different thought
process with different things and that's
where i'm at in life and you know what
i'm saying like you're not
in this in bold advice if you don't
learn how to be the bigger person you're
never going to be successful bro you
have facts you have to take sacrifices
and you know what i'm saying to uh just
know what you're doing bro you feel me
so you know what i'm saying you know
what's funny man
if you bro you know what's funny if you
would have asked flight about what he
just said to y'all right now
a year and a half ago he wouldn't have
told you that that wouldn't have been
his attitude
that's how much this [ __ ] has grown you
know what i'm saying
flight usually he's he's a he's a leo so
he's
he's very passionate how you're gonna
turn that into a game i feel you it's
needed video sorry i like don't
i don't want to listen to this guy i
just want to hear the video which i
wouldn't be surprised she does
i mean you guys know i get down and
react to it and you know and we got the
receipts and all that stuff but i'm not
gonna i'm gonna say the main [ __ ]
that i have the right to just not have
to deal with her anymore and just be a
problem how you're gonna turn that into
a game
i gotta i gotta go back like shady
sneaky things um she like i said she she
has a manipulation factor
um the biggest recent thing which i'm
moving on for
um from from going to stuff in places so
i don't because i don't want to like
make this video like 30 40 minutes you
notice i don't want to sit here
he does end up being 40 minutes now
unless she goes ahead and but i feel
like it's needed a video which i
wouldn't be surprised she does i mean
you guys know i get down and react to it
and you know and we got the receipts and
all that stuff
okay so he wanted to just okay
okay the main [ __ ] that i have the right
to just not have to deal with her
anymore and just be a proper co-prayer
you know what i'm saying for my
beautiful daughter on the way um
the biggest thing that's really made us
clash
is her controlling factor like i said
she would literally tell me
who i can and can't follow you know i'm
saying like first of all
she's not my boss you feel me this was
something that was honestly the biggest
clash not the biggest but one of the
biggest slashing points since like
february of this year in 2020 and like
it eventually got worse and worse and
honestly it got to a point where i just
wanted to be the bigger man you see
um she does a lot of things too she's
one of those type of girls that try and
play
victim to like oh um using the kid as a
victim and all that stuff yeah
so you know she threw that out but she
was like oh so you have a kid on the way
don't disrespect me with women you
follow on social media
okay it's certain ones boom i did that
you know follow them even though i
didn't want so i didn't have problems
with them you know what i'm saying just
didn't want to make them you know feel
no type of way
i went and did that one thing before we
get too deep into this video man
okay that should have been kept private
i'm sorry that that could have been that
should have been kept private
i think that's more common than you
would think in relationships which
apparently they weren't in one so i
don't think she had a right to do that
um but honestly if my mom told my dad to
unfollow someone it would not be a
problem
he would literally just say okay um
so i i do think if you're in a
relationship or dating someone
um you should be respectful in who you
follow
i have to say this this isn't this isn't
i told you so
to flight at all baby congrats
you [ __ ] okay oh you're not a good
homie
it's just i knew it i could just tell
bro
is she doing the same is she out of it
because
you know getting out of a situation like
that [ __ ] is not easy bro
it's not easy because these females be
oh my gosh
man man oh man
now is she doing the same thing
no you know what i'm saying she's
literally like following people she's
literally
you know i'm saying dated in the past
actually all that stuff
and it got to a point where i had to
like check though i had to call her out
and it was happening like july you know
what i'm saying of this year 2020
and like i'm just like okay so why are
you telling me who to who i can and
can't follow
but you're doing your thing you know i'm
saying that she puts excuse like oh but
i've known these people since like high
school
and all you know i'm not saying like why
are you getting the best of both worlds
no i would agree it shouldn't be if
she's asking that of him
it should be me that's like small stuff
you know i'm saying we're moving on
now another thing which just made me
really turned off it's just like
everything you have to realize flight
likes this drama on some level
um i i read there's like a science
behind it like the highs and the lows
um it makes it like addicting for your
brain
because you started all of this and at
the end of the day he's saying all this
stuff
that like really should have been kept
private
and i don't think this makes him look
good i'm not gonna lie to you
every time we would chill together bro
she's just mad toxic bro
as soon as i see her the first five
things that comes out of her mouth
is literally let me see her phone or she
tries to reach for my phone like what
bro you know what i'm saying she's dead
i remember one time um when i got my uh
hell no
toxic issues been going on you know i'm
saying i've been dealing with it and the
reason
honestly why is because she i'm not
gonna put her her business what happened
in her past
she had a really messed up past and i
was just really trying to uplift her and
just like you know what i'm saying like
you know
get back to like her her her normal
jolly
you know self um when we had met she had
just some trash things that happened in
the past when it came like exes and you
know traumatic things
so that's the main reason what honestly
kept me around you would know what
happened
you feel me you'll be like okay you feel
me
yeah someone like that but also at the
same time i never like try to lead her
on like i wanted her to be my guy
like i'm not ready and she understood it
got cool
no she did it no she didn't no she
didn't
i'm sorry but if a girl is sleeping with
you consistently she wants a
relationship she might
cap to her to her friends she might cap
to the boy she might even cap to herself
that she's cool with this she's
only cool with it because that's what
she can get i'm sorry
99 of the time no she didn't
she made it seem like she did
girls will not understand that there is
no there is no under
even if you not lead in the morning
just the fact that you're even giving
them that space they're already like
yeah he's leading me on
that's just how women think bro
that's just how the [ __ ] they think bro
they're not hearing none of that [ __ ]
they might be like oh it verbally like
yeah yeah no i
yeah thank you yeah i understand you're
not leaving me on you
but secretly they're like oh yeah i got
this [ __ ] you know that's just how they
think bro
these women are just they're different
bro they're different
what i'm saying now you know fast
forwarding on
um back in 2019 when i got my uh my
first forum which was the
uh the the the beginning mercedes i got
the cls
uh 550 uh this is like a month you know
what i'm saying we were in the car and i
picked up we're gonna go go to benihada
and we were driving like a hilly thing
if he did you know um there's a certain
mini hotter spot to la
um there's one i think we're doing like
all the way until paying them all they
got like hilly's you know i'm saying
hills
you go up and stuff and mind you you
know what i'm saying when i'm going
through that you know what i'm saying
like you might use two lanes you can't
just have room to just be messing around
swerving
right bro how would you feel you know
what i'm saying if somebody literally
grabbed your phone
and she literally tried to drive me off
the road like she's literally a threat
to my life you feel me
so this is another reason why i wanted
to make it wait did she grab your phone
or try to drive you off the road i'm so
i'm confused here did i miss something i
feel like it's something god forbid
you know what i'm saying knock on wood
because at the end of the day sometimes
you just be saying things just so you
know i'm saying when she
just be mad but if anything happens to
me everybody
i'm just saying you feel me like i've
had like a couple of like
really scary situations and damn don't
drive
i'm not trying to be insensitive but
sometimes i don't think men hold other
men accountable
honestly you picked her dude you picked
her you don't have a right to come on
this
online and offer up all the details of
your relationship
one-sided um you picked her dude
walk parkway dogs and all that [ __ ] and
basically was just like
you know i gotta calm her down for 20 30
minutes and you know what i'm saying the
next couple days she ends up apologizing
you know
stuff like this she does her things i
don't like she does apologize sometimes
you know what i'm saying but it's only
to a certain extent where enough is
enough
right that's the fact he's gonna
eventually try to apologize to try and
draw me back in like a fish
you know that's what they do but it's
just it's got to the point you know i'm
saying like
so you know fast food on that's just
like one out of like 30
40 things you know what i'm saying so i
just want you guys to kind of get like a
a taste of details on what's necessarily
going on because i don't want to just be
like oh like she did this toxic things
and then people don't be liking it okay
and do you know how selfish this
is it's one thing okay this this bothers
me it's one thing
if you are in
a relationship okay and you guys break
up
but you got a kid involved my guy so
you're thinking about
like i want to make this video because
either
she pointed me in like a certain light
right and i don't like it
so i don't want to look like that so i'm
going to make this video to save my
reputation
or you're saying i'm gonna make this
video so i feel better about the
situation get my fans on my side
flight it's not about you
i'm sorry but you got a kid do you think
this is good to have on the internet
when your kid gets older do you think
that's that's fair
what about all your kids friends they're
gonna they might see this someday like
that's just i think it
it irks me if you want to make yourself
look like an idiot they both look stupid
to me
but if you want to make yourself look
like an idiot and there's no kids
involved
fine go at it but at some point it's not
about you it's about your kid
and behind the screen like [ __ ] what
toxic things you just be saying that
you know what i'm saying i just don't
want to i just don't have time to sit
here for 40 50 minutes now like i said
if she makes her video and tries to
put me make me look bad and cat and [ __ ]
and like that
you know what i'm saying i thought she's
but she she made no she's not that
stupid like believe me
she's not that [ __ ] dumb dog i'm
saying um
when it was my kid it's just undeniably
i was already gonna do that i had
nothing to you know what i'm saying but
like even worse than that
nobody's she's going to get [ __ ] up
[ __ ] ass
[ __ ] if she even dares making a video
just wanted to make that clear [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like i'm
prepared but you know i didn't want to
take you there we're just going to like
the juicy things
which is the reason why you know i'm
just moving on and just being a bigger
man and just going to be an amazing dope
as
co-parent and it's mind you when i've
been a cop i'm still gonna provide and
support
you know what i'm saying like you know
everything like that like when it comes
to like money
uh for her you know what i'm saying um
when it was my kid is just
undeniably i was already gonna do that i
had nothing you know what i'm saying but
like even for her i'm even
offering to do that but she's trying so
hard to like bully me into a
relationship you guys kind of see where
i'm going here you know what i'm saying
it's like
she's used to having like [ __ ] like
sent out for her
and like the first or second night just
you know being like oh
i'm ready to date you and this and that
yeah and she ran into me it's just i'm a
different breeder also i
you know i have been hurt in the past
and all this stuff and you guys and
stuff so i'm just more like on point
yeah that's a fact you know i'm saying
like just just
firm and blunt with certain things all
right so moving on you know i'm saying
let's go back into july i just wanted to
get a little bit of a
background into some details and so you
guys get a knowledge on what's really
going down
all right so you know getting down into
july you know what i'm saying i had my
video shoot for disingenious you know
what i'm saying this doesn't
genius um and i came home that day you
know what i'm saying to mind you
we are not together and in july also
mind you too she didn't uh tell me like
she was like pregnant
you know what i'm saying until like
after you know what i'm saying
but she basically you know i'm saying
she this is another red flag that's why
i have to be done with because it's like
now it's getting it to a point where
it's just like an invasion of pride
nina yes you better not trap me
why would i trap you i mean
i'm just kidding
[ __ ] around look like flight up here man
see
beyond taking the phone and stuff bro
she does too many times where she
literally will pull up to my crib bro
she
obviously you know i'm saying we've
chilled before so she knows where i stay
you know so she literally pulls up to my
crib
you know what i'm saying and literally
you know what i'm saying just invades my
privacy
she pulls up to my crib multiple times
like trying to hit on me you know i'm
saying grab me by my neck and it's the
thing is
that she's trying to bait me to like
really you know what i'm saying give her
the damn left and right
but you know yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah good [ __ ] flight
she does all that that is growth right
there that is growth because like i said
man
sorry guys i don't i don't want to be
like that guy i just get
skeptical when i see like a pattern of
someone in relationships
that everything's exactly how they say
it but if she's putting her hands on him
he should call the cops he should 100
call police
the most annoying to hit them bro you
know
don't show her no [ __ ] that's what she
wanted
now you got a lawsuit good [ __ ] flight
like crazy top issues girls like just
completely like a psycho head bro
you know what i'm saying uh so anyway
that disingenuous shoot i came home
and you know i just keep it a buck you
know so i'm not gonna tell who the girl
is name and all that stuff but like i
brought up a girl from disingenuous
shoot you know i'm saying we chill we
had a wine and smoke and you know we did
our thing
next night or the next morning you know
what i'm saying um i'm walking around
you know i'm saying go to an uber
you know what i'm saying and
she literally slept in her car for two
hours bro
she slept in her car for two hours bro
waiting you know what i'm saying just
like anticipating what i'm going to kind
of because she kind of like
guessed when i honestly was going to go
you know i'm staying out
and so as soon as i leave out and i'm
like you know i'm staying close to
downstairs she's there
she's trying to you know threaten do
this whatever to the girl they she
doesn't do anything like i keep her from
doing that that ends up the
monster shirt the girl from that video
shoot ends up leaving
you know what i'm saying and um you know
i end up you know
she follows me back to my career based i
did not invite her i did not want her in
here wait a minute i'm so confused the
girl
okay
okay obviously like clearly the girl
shouldn't do that but
i just like flight what are you doing
[ __ ] around with all these females
when you got a kid on the way
am i the only one like everyone's like
oh flight flight flight he's
so good which i mean
i don't know him personally but just in
relationships
i don't know so as soon as i leave out
and i'm like you know i'm saying close
to downstairs she's there
she's trying to you know threaten do
this whatever to the girl they she
doesn't do anything
oh my god uh the girl from that video
shoot
ends up leaving you know what i'm saying
and um you know i ended up what
follows me back to my [ __ ] race i did
not invite her i did not want her in
here
sorry guys i had to change my camera
battery but yeah she ends up following
me to my crib
and then she gets into my crib now mind
you like i can't like just
yank her by her hair and just like yeah
shove her she's gonna flop like lebron
she gonna flop like lebron [ __ ] around
get a black eye off of a flock
now it's your fault
i'm trying to tell you bro it's really
the hardest thing if you can't even like
do you can't even like she wants to have
the best of both worlds but when i'm
about to really move on to be happy
that's what she wants to swoop in yeah
you know what i'm saying
and just like no you're not gonna be
happy if i'm being sad you're gonna be
you know what i'm saying uh sad too or
mad you know i'm saying that's just like
the
the sickening thing about this girl like
she's really trying her hardest to tear
down
you know what i'm saying me as an
individual because she sees like the
blessings that i got this year
yeah and sees that my life is going up
when we first met in 2018 like i keep it
a but
you know what i'm saying like i was
really stagnant with my career you know
i'm saying like
i was you know i don't i'm not gonna you
know put money in how much i was making
and everything but i was you know making
something where it was just like
it was little boy [ __ ] to me the way i
was looking at it you know now yeah you
know what i'm saying yeah
you know make it now so it's like that's
a blessing upgrade she just became like
like self she developed animosity over
time
and that was an amazing vocab word bro
that i just you know take
that out right now develop animosity
over time just
envy imagine like i was never i never do
to be like no i'm saying oh
bust down yeah you're not you know what
i'm saying no i don't you know do that
like i was all you
past videos like when it was her
birthday last year and i got her you
know what i'm saying i bought her a
kitchen all that stuff that was around
the time i bought my new car and
literally also when i got those presents
that was like
three weeks two weeks three weeks
probably when she did that little
cartons to try to force me off the road
you know what i'm saying um so basically
you guys also wonder when she's trying
to force me on the road so people are
not speculating what happened
i ended up having to grab both of her
wrists and i'm like literally forced her
to keep it on her left and i was driving
with one hand you know what i'm saying
at the time
um so i i had so much like um
okay so it sounds like she was just
crazy
jealous like she wanted to be in a
relationship she wanted that loyalty
he didn't want to give it to her and
so she went to extreme lengths to
secure that he was loyal basically i
want to get myself for not taking her
further
you should give her a couple of jabs and
hay makers and everything like that so i
draw home guys
up to that part and uh and i talked her
out she cooled down and i just ended up
taking her you know i'm staying home
that day
uh but anyway man back on what i was
talking about bro it's just like i'm
sorry if you guys if i feel like i'm
everywhere bro
it's just i'm trying to tell you guys
what's up in like the shortest amount of
time possible because i don't want you
all to be up here for an hour
hearing a grown-ass man man like i said
it's gonna be the left the the first and
last time
i do a video like this well actually
this i just like second time yeah the
last time i did it was with my
um that afternoon i made that similar
video this is the type of video i'm
trying to make right now so i can you
know
let the public know if you see me with
like you know another girl or whatever
you know what i'm saying don't be like
oh fly you a [ __ ] [ __ ] or you just
doing your baby monologue
mind you it took me up this damn near
almost two years for this to happen
almost a year
you know what i'm saying on some low
ball stuff all right so mind you after
the disingenuous video shoot and all
that stuff happened
you know what i'm saying um she's in my
crib imagine that um me and that girl
from this video's video shoot
we had one with wine and smoke we had
some great wine the
leftover wine was on my counter in my
career so what she ends up literally
doing she just snaps after five minutes
of being there she takes the wine bottle
and she doesn't throw the wine bottle
itself thank god
but she chucks it enough to where the
wine liquid you know
that's it when when a girl is getting
angry that that means she still wants to
f
with you because otherwise what is there
to be angry over
like if she's if she's doing all this
[ __ ] like that means
i still want to be with you guys same
same thing
she should have just laughed she said
okay you want to [ __ ] with these females
go ahead and laugh
you know and not done all that crazy
stuff too
kind like pores are like you know if you
have like a big ass jug of water you can
just like fling it and it'll be just
enough to come across bro
so i had like six or seven pairs of
shoes it wasn't like some heat even if
it was
i'm blessed enough to buy some more okay
i think i understand i'm gonna
skip a little further in the video but
she's gotta kick that with like her
family or whatever
you know what i'm saying or cut or
cousins or sisters or something just
girls night out
and she end up was twerking on a dude
like a dude literally grabbed her by the
hips and i and you know that's obviously
where the lyric now the t
is out you know i'm saying that's where
that layer came from the disingenious
um so yeah anyway that happened and
that's the main reason what made me done
like
when it was december last year i was
ready to leave this girl in 2019
you know what i'm saying she drew me
back like a fish on some trapping [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like this is
like i have the right to say like at
this point
she's just like full-on trying to trap
me for home toxic reasons you know what
i'm saying she's trying to
finesse and try and rob me out of my
money and she's always
also you know putting that child support
thing out there and everything like
that's why i've been trying so hard to
be cordial with her and work things out
you know what i'm saying because i don't
want to have her have her take things to
the court system but at this time
i don't give a [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying do whatever you got to do you
know what i'm saying
um so anyway um after that you know 2019
over you know saying like i said again
you guys this is probably like the the
the weirdest storytelling
it's just like writing a story and then
like speaking on things later in the
chapter and then going back and forth
you know what i'm saying but i just want
to make sure you guys get enough juicy
details and talk
talking why why because he wants to make
himself look better
not thinking about your future family
not thinking about your free future kids
you're thinking about you
that's wrong i'm sorry it's so wrong to
put all this out there especially if you
have a kid
you know what i'm saying um topics or
whatever ideas
what i'm dealing with you know what i'm
saying so mind you it's all just right
now i already know that she
is pregnant and everything the entire
month of august bro
bro probably is the like worst month
ever i've ever experienced with her bro
she literally uh does nothing but just
degrading me as a character
she says some just really really deep
hatred ass things
you know i'm just not going to be
another four-year-old and be like oh she
called me a whip
you know i'm just not you know i just
don't have time for that but hell no
as a respectful man it's just certain
things like i understand people have
pregnancy
withdrawals or symptoms and this and
that but when you're mad bro it's just
like you really meant that and the thing
about it is that she said certain things
kind of around what she said to me in
degrading ways before she was even
pregnant but now this is icing on the
cake you know what i'm saying she says
just degrading things like you know from
little little thing examples i'm trying
to make sure i get some devices
okay i think i get it so basically
super controlling um
crazy girl fine he starts it so he puts
this online
then it goes back to this where she's
like apologizing saying she shouldn't
have did it that way
i wrote i could have did something
stupid you know what i'm saying so it's
just like
you know i don't buy any of that you
know but um
just hopefully you know what i'm saying
she learns a lesson for like the next
dude whoever you know i'm saying she has
you know what i'm saying not to uh mess
up hey it's not the first time
but did you learn a lesson probably not
um we've been through things and i'm
saying
like it's never been to the point where
we take anything to the internet
i feel like it just we just got caught
up in like a situation where
we both had enough and we just you know
turned up and he decided to take it to
the internet and
then i'm just over there trolling and
stuff about the situation
that i shouldn't have and um yeah
like and then i think she was hooking up
with like
the 16 year old which is
gross i don't know i just feel
bad that i did that honestly like it's
not in my heart to be doing things like
that
you know at the end of the day um you
are the father of my daughter
and i couldn't be happier you know
to be the mother of my daughter our
daughter
i'm sorry but my
my interpretation is they literally
deserve each other
and they both need to go to therapy
and at the end of the day it's a
blessing in disguise to be able to even
you know carry a child in me
and i thank you for that for giving me
an opportunity to
to be able to experience a whole new
love
um also i want to take it back to how i
said that
you know i started changing within time
i can admit that
and anyone who knows me even in my
family they know i can catch a little
attitude sometimes you know
um i can be stubborn i can be
hard-headed
i can just be self-centered it's just a
lot to it that i feel like
you know could be different
um it's crazy because
i do remember being nice too um the
times when me and um
kamani verde started being together like
not together
but i'm saying like talking dating wise
whatever
like i used to be i used to think like
you know down
like i love this kid i don't love him
for what he does
what he brings to the table but i love
him for who he is as a person himself
genuine and just brought me out of my
shell
before him i was caught up in a
four-year relationship
when i met flight it was like i had
already a year broken up in that
relationship but i was still caught up
like you know
and fly brought me out of that he made
me be myself again after that i will
always have love for him
um and i just remember like
you know just being that sweet girl to
him
just giving him my all and
i would even probably about his crib
like yo
yeah yeah
like it's just that that was really you
know i'm saying realistically like the
main main part was just
like that [ __ ] right there it's just
like
it's a it's invasion of privacy you know
i'm saying like he wasn't gonna just
continue to just walk and
continue to walk over me i'm trying to
bully you know what i'm saying into a
relationship because of that
pulling up to the crib factor you know
what i'm saying because you know that i
can't really do anything you know what
i'm saying that's how
that was you knew what you was doing you
know saying you baited me to do
something so
you call the police um you know i'm
saying probably blow up off the
situation who knows you know i'm saying
even now looking back on it like
right now you know what i'm saying and
you know like i said like that video
that i did the statute that probably
like now think about bro it definitely
is probably
without a doubt in my like youtube of
all time it's my top five favorite
videos you know what i'm saying of mine
bro
because that like in so many ways that
people really knew like it saved my life
in so many categories and
it's a lot of w's behind it you know
what i'm saying like only to like the
the trolling hayden you know i'm saying
[ __ ] that don't be getting you know
i'm saying girls
you don't have to be grounded or
anything like that you know what i'm
saying they you know they're of course
going to be over there
saying quick he's going to keep
repeating this cycle
he's going to keep doing the same thing
over and over again
he learns no lessons and you have to
think about
like that's so selfish you're making it
about
you like that oh my god i do not
i do not respect people with children or
children on the way that put their
business on the internet that is not
fair to your kids
that's not fair and he has no regret no
remorse
i was sad but you know at the end of the
day i'm here on this earth you know what
i'm saying
for a reason you know people learn
lessons you know what i'm saying at the
end of the day you know i'm saying
you know i got a beautiful daughter on
the way you know um
but you know with that being said it's
just
that was the case right there you know
i'm saying invasion of privacy like
there is no reason where you found out
that that was okay
um and it's just just plain and simple
like
there's nothing else to jenny no no
i just talked about his crib like yo i
brought you groceries like this and that
well she's talking about something like
different but i'm talking about just
popping up in the crib but just me
because
[Applause]
look at my eyes but just me because um
you know me being the big hearted person
that i am i should think back to myself
and i still do to this day like
you know flying's a real hustler like he
came out here to l.a
about two three years ago you feel me he
has nobody out here
he's just doing it all on his own he
don't have family out here
none of that and he don't really do much
you know he doesn't really hang out with
people so i feel like
i can't imagine myself you know being
from my family
away from my family since you know i'm a
family's girl like
i can't imagine just being away from my
family in another state
and just you know not being close to
them
and that's why i used to think to myself
like i just want to love him
more and show him love and you know
not only pop up at his house just to
hang out and stuff i used to always
cater to him
take him groceries fill up his whole
fridge
i used to just be that in china yeah she
did stop
like i mean we gotta kind of get on to
the point like you know i mean that's
facts like i mean yes she did but it's
just like that's not what the issue was
i never complained about that
one time in the sad truth i never said
anything like that but
one thing i can say is that i didn't
stop because
what's what i'm saying i'm sure there's
more i'm sure she was giving him like a
lot of relationship
privileges that she shouldn't have but
this is why i say there's two sides to
every story but
no the like stuff he was saying about
her acting crazy
that's nuts i wanted to when people
start
switching up on me and stuff i might
forgive
that's that's actually true about me i
forgive a lot
i forgive i keep forgiving i keep
forgiving
but i don't forget so once someone
starts switching up on me
i see it i get you know my feelings
whatever
i don't really try to express myself
that much but i just
act accordingly you know and so like i
stopped doing it because of certain
things that we would go through
and i'm like why am i putting my own to
something that
i feel like i'm not getting the same
love back
you know like but i was still there i
was still nice you know this and that
and everything was good you know like
any other couple or dating couple
whatever you want to call it
everybody goes through things so you
won't you always want to forgive that
person that you love
and just you know
think that everything everything's just
going to be better and get better and
that was my situation i kept forgiving
forgiving forgiving you know
and i'm not going to sit here and say i
didn't do things either that you know
could have bothered flight or father
flight
like i did it and i admit that and i
mean you have to give me two
for gaming we both just kept having that
thought like you know things are gonna
get better we would always say things
are gonna get better
um this and that and um we always
forgave each other we came together
that's why nothing went to the internet
like
flight knows and everybody around me
knows that as much as
i can love some attention i don't i'm
not for the internet
i don't i don't care about the internet
i don't run isn't she have an only fan
to the internet for any little thing
that's not my type of time i don't get
like that and i will never
um and this time when i went on live and
stuff like that
that was just out of my character and i
just reacted without thinking
but honestly
he she barely did anything on that live
she really barely did if that's the lie
they're talking about she barely did
anything
other than that i just feel like damn i
don't know
i'm all over the place right now
but
yeah like you know people change
once you start going through things this
is a whole different vibe it's a whole
different everything
and in this moment like you know i'm not
just trying to put the blame on me
because like i said like and i can admit
actually
flight did say that once i got pregnant
like four months ago
i started i changed even for the worst
and i can admit that
my attitude got worse you know um
my attitude got worse i started being
more meaner to him
i just tried to understand him in
certain things but then i
everything we just been through was
always in the back of my head so i feel
like i would just come harder for him
like
in some situations i cannot admit okay
i'm gonna skip a little bit
you know i can i can see why
actually let me let me just explain a
little bit of i said i was gonna make it
short but let me just
prove my point i'm probably just
rambling to you guys but
i'm just like i've even thought about
not doing the video today because i
still want to get some things like
clear like on my head but it's whatever
um
i speed in the video the way this all
happened to was because
basically you know you better thank me
right now bro
thank you because i just guessed that
setting out
so i made the video playback to be like
1.5 and it's speeding up instead of just
like the constant like pauses and
everything in the senses
you know i'm saying like in flight
already have been going through it like
starting my pregnancy it got just bad
i might slow down i'm just trying to
make it work but
you know eventually i got pregnant and
not to
not mention me and flight have always
talked about having like kids together
we've always said like we want to be
together we always say we love each
other we always say this and that
and i can tell if he's like what so
you're telling this
girl you want to have kids with her and
that you love her and then you're
confused when
she wants a relationship
um
i know the mannose fear is going to
roast me but
they both are nuts like a family's guy
like he's very nice he's genuine he's
loving like he'll do anything
for his family so that's one of the
things why too it makes me feel so bad
even inside because it's like
if we wanted this and we already spoke
into existence why we gotta act like
that
like why we gotta just do too much you
know but
nobody's perfect i mean it all happens
you know
i also um i was gonna switch to the
topic oh yeah
of like the way things happened was uh
everything was already kind of like bad
um especially by the time i got pregnant
you know i started being
more my feelings i started having more
mood swings i just
you know i got really out of my
character i'm not gonna lie um
and like i said it's just due to me
being hurt and just you know trying to
be ten toes on everything
and i feel like god never really turns
me down when i have
like an idea of something that could be
happening behind my back so what it was
it's like you know we're having a baby
like we're happy we're just trying to be
the best we can
we're good this and that and then
next thing you know like we're good like
what two weeks ago
we were good we were perfectly fine i
mean we were going through things but
like we just like always we always try
to solve it and not make a big deal out
of it
but this time what happened was like
we were good and he was telling me he
was going out of state
you know because he was going to look at
houses you know so we can eventually
move to a house for a daughter
and stuff like that you know me being
like the caring person and just
even okay so one thing i can't say like
on a man's stuff
yes i did say i was going out of state
but i did not say the lines of all that
type of stuff janet you know what i'm
saying you knew that i was going out of
state to look at different houses and
properties and also going on a mental
break because i haven't been out to
state
since the beginning of the year because
of the railroad going on and everything
like that you know what i'm saying in
which
shorts and i kind of know where she's
going to go on to the topic i'm going to
let her finish on you know what i'm
saying
but though my trust issues are messed up
even though you know i've been going
through this i always just try to like
believe this person believe him and
be like okay i trust you like you know
go on to your trip go look at the houses
you know i'm gonna be good you know just
check in with me and your daughter and
like be straight
i mean with me but obviously i'm
carrying his daughter um
that's how it was like you know on
friday like two weeks ago
he was like you know since he woke up he
checked on me he said he's about to take
he's about to go to the airport he's
about to take flight and he
like you know called me when he got off
the airport he was getting into his
he was just checking in on me like i
said the whole the whole situation was
that we were fine right
so he texted me telling me oh i'm
heading to the airport you know i'll let
you know when i land when i get to my
hotel so
um to to like let's get it started he's
first he told me he was going to be in a
room because we were planning to like he
was planning to look at houses in
arizona and vegas so um
he told me he was going to go to arizona
first so i'm like okay you know like
just go whatever
enjoy and have your space and look at
the houses whatever
and so that's not what she said you know
what i'm saying uh
basically the day before um like i said
this is not a bastion video whatsoever
but you know i just don't want things
that you know i'm saying to get a [ __ ]
up you know what i'm saying with things
that actually didn't happen
all right so basically the day before
you know i'm saying like she already
knew this stuff was gonna happen i was
supposed to go this and that
you know what i'm saying and she pretty
much was just like oh no i'm gonna just
go with you you know what i'm saying
like on some controlling [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying that mind you
beforehand three to four days beforehand
she already was talking about we already
agreed to like
move on you know what i'm saying we
doing our own thing and that's it you
know it's just no if ands or buts about
it like because it was just getting so
toxic
there was just no other you know what
i'm saying really route that
i honestly wanted to go and honestly she
wanted to go to be honest we wanted to
i honestly wanted to been make it this
way for like the past two months you
know what i'm saying but when she got
pregnant i kind of
try to do it then but i just came to
figure out like
that [ __ ] is just not gonna help you out
you know what i'm saying it's just it's
just
no no matter what a kid is just not
gonna help anybody that's truthfully not
meant to be
together around each other like that or
prevent them from being toxic
to go away you know what i'm saying so
basically we already came to an
agreement literally like three to four
days ago like move on you know what i'm
saying do your own thing
and even mind you guys towards this time
i hope she admits this but like
when we're getting an argument she's
mentioning you know what i'm saying
comparing me to other dudes you know i'm
saying she would low-key like you know
what i'm saying like telling herself
like she would literally
like talk about like dudes that she's
literally talking to she would always
screenshot
and try to rub on my face and all this
types of weird [ __ ] like oh look who i'm
talking to
you know i'm saying this and that and
then all of a sudden like when i try to
move on and get away she'd come back and
apologize
the same thing i was talking about in
the video she would always come back and
reel me in with the apologies
and this like that and act like she
wasn't talking uh you know i'm saying
the dudes anymore which was really
stupid of me because like you can't just
especially like woman nowadays they're
not gonna just cut off a dude
just like that you know what i'm saying
unless you do something to that girl
where they just
whatever most of the time nine times
that 10 they're not cut them off
especially
you know i'm saying lh [ __ ] you feel me
so i that was the thing i messed up on
like i said i don't want nobody to feel
bad about like
anything that happened or anything i've
been said that you know what i'm saying
like that's what i was just starting
referring to like the trolls and haters
there's something they're saying like oh
flight wants us to feel bad from like
[ __ ] i did not say one time in the
video i do not want y'all to feel bad
for me
i'm speaking out you know what i'm
saying as a okay but
flight why else would you put that video
out
i'm sorry but people can come to
conclusions like i i can't think of a
good incentive you have
to put that video out you want your fans
on your side that's fine
just admit that lesson you know i'm
saying to people so they don't go to the
same thing i'm going through and also
as an escape video so i don't do
something stupid and that's you know
what i'm saying to
successfully and peacefully move on you
know what i'm saying which literally
happened that was probably the biggest
the biggest fattest w low key that you
know what i'm saying a lot of people
don't realize
but yes not saying the plane is simple
see like all those reasons
other than the like this is an example
for other people but there's a way you
can do that without exposing
your baby mama i'm sorry it's selfish
when we came to the agreement okay i
think i have an idea i'm not going to
keep watching that
um okay this is 40 minutes oh my god
i already watched this one
oh and i think this is a video of his
new relationship
watch watch it's going to be a pattern
delete the tweet no you're not
what the [ __ ]
come on let me put this in
fast speed
delete it get your phone for the tweet
narrow come on daddy delete it
yes
you want to show them the set of a
relationship we're going to show them we
do this all the time like all the time
like if i told you if i have to ever
tweet out something that i'm saying that
means it's not looking back cause you
pushed me there so it's like
chances i don't care it's too insecure
about searching you're insecure too
yes you are we're not gonna start i'm
not gonna embarrass you and say how
should you do
the meme yeah see i
i tell i guarantee there's more to it
you are what you attract
guys you literally are what you tracked
oh my gosh watches in the back together
my words yeah i'm not looking
no you know look what you're not going
to don't touch my eyes all this [ __ ] is
off
he's starting to smile he he kind of
missed her
i'm gonna continue to swing that's fine
let me do this [ __ ] all the time like i
don't care if you wanna show it to
everyone
tell them how you want to break up an
engagement i mean there's no point
it's off like you want me to say is he
still dating this girl
no i'm not enough i'm still trying no
i'm still streaming
i'm gonna go to his instagram maybe that
would say trying to find if they're
still together
um
it's obviously i can't do [ __ ] like
right now like
i'm just probably i'm i don't want to
but i'm in the stream and talk off game
but everything still remains like
i'm still single all that no he's not
you're saying no he's not i promise you
once we're done talking he's not even
going to mind his words
hurry up hurry up like
just i don't want to like have you guys
into the mix of it like i apologize
okay pattern okay now the new one
baby okay so it's not it's not her wait
i'm so confused
because flight edit that in bro like
he's hilarious as [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what do you do flight crew
ftc
i hate doing these types of video you
guys but
no you don't
stop saying that it's just gotten to a
point where enough is enough
enough is enough you said that in the
everything
man you said that in every video it's
just not true
but i've already been saying this and
i've been trying to grow myself to
continue to learn how to defend myself
when it just comes to people continuing
to take advantage of my kindness
take advantage of my kindness over and
over over and continue to take advantage
of my kindness continue to kick me down
you know container get me down to down
to down and down now as you guys know
what i'm probably gonna be talking about
the most bitter
child's mother how do you want to call
like big mom you know what i'm saying
she's just the most disgusting human
hateful what he's baby mom yeah he's a
kid with a girl
dang why is he going off on her she was
she did some [ __ ] up [ __ ] to him
she uh men never hold each other
accountable
i'm sorry look at it i and i get it
women don't either
but like god damn guys does anyone see
this like i see it
or is this just me cheating on him i
think like while she's pregnant or some
[ __ ]
no okay but he was he was doing the same
thing
and he said they were never together it
doesn't matter yeah adhd fine we're
going back to one
two thousand dollars we're going back to
normal bro you were laughing because you
knew i was thinking that i know i know
but now we're going back to normal bro
yo chat suck my dick human being like i
just never thought you know what i'm
saying like i would literally have
somebody that you know is so much of a
hater
that i know you know what i'm saying
like i didn't know it's possible like
it's literally so true the close the
the biggest haters are somebody that's
closest to you that you think
is on your side man and honestly it's
just been
since she's damn near been prego um and
then me you know what i'm saying
you know moving on and separating you
know what i'm saying in terms of just
moving on and being happy um and you
know
being into a relationship and continuing
to go strong and everything man
i literally have a notepad man because i
just fed up had it um i completely just
fed up you know what i'm saying a lot of
people are gonna be at this point typing
fierce and it comes flight go to court
go to court
from this you know day on four
everything's literally gonna be done
with the court process and everything
like that
fcc now i actually forgot to state it
the way i wanted to but basically uh
i hate to say this but this has been
going on since october dude you should
have been to court
the reason why i'm also doing this video
too because a lot of you guys fcc
brothers and sisters have been asking me
to update on june
my daughter and everything like that so
this is also an update video all the
ones that you guys know with the stuff
dealing with behind the scenes now it's
the wrestling
um you know just to backtrack a little
bit um it looked like it seemed like
things was cool between atlantic um
your child my child's mother whatever
you want to call her it's either landed
on my child's mother those are the only
two options you can call her
um everybody should address her like um
you know
since that sad truth video you know i'm
saying it's literally been hell like i
know on this channel like i made a video
um talking about like all the beef was
settled and this and that
with me here and honestly wasn't i
literally went out my way to be a better
man
um you know to first of all i'm not
gonna pause that much but i know what
he's talking about like sometimes you
just don't want to create drama beef
with certain people on social media
because it's gonna actually like
stir up [ __ ] and like yeah i know you
mean like basically just
because my daughter was literally about
to be born i think it was like the the
day or two before she was about to be
born you know i'm saying her a little
bit after
anyways like throw up just bring
positive energy you know what i'm saying
like
energy to you know um new flesh that
hurts hell abuser
first kid my daughter and everything
like that i just try to be the bigger
man as a person even when i made that
video
it's not up no more i believe um but
thanks was not even at seven percent you
know what i'm saying it wasn't even
nowhere near man
um the number one thing
me and i've been really strong [ __ ]
since
honestly the sad truth video like even
when i told you like just now i made the
video of me trying to like make [ __ ]
closer with the um um
a child's mother like it wasn't you know
what i'm saying um the number one thing
uh since
you know my daughter's been born is that
she literally
mood when you swear you seeing j lmao
ugly ass
okay have a good night
huh
damn weirdo
have a good night sleeping no you ain't
gonna see her over being a dummy
what the [ __ ] lmao did i tell you i
changed jay's middle and last name
that's wrong that's so [ __ ] up bro
yeah that's
i agree that's wrong that's toxic really
really [ __ ] up that's actually
really [ __ ] up good luck thinking you
had it what
still wishing you a good day who texts
like that
literally dangles like the time i can
spend with my daughter
just like a piece of string wait i can't
see it
you gotta either take me shopping what
you gotta either
there's no way that's real you gotta
either take me shopping or matter of
fact give me 20k
and def say the [ __ ] sorry ella or
even bother your time is up
bro what but either like
that's i don't even believe this is real
bro this is not [ __ ] real there's no
way he what if he doesn't
then he won't see his daughter yeah
would you ever do that to me no question
i know you wouldn't
oh he's so in love but you come on move
on why you always screaming
thanks imagine me going outside when i'm
the one who damn near dropped you played
yourself buddy nice try though i just
hit a lick
bro what what what does hit a lick mean
i don't know what that means
spitting bars what's going on i'll move
the camera move the camera i got you
i'm saying or just plain and simple just
it's like trying to find a cure to
cancer [ __ ] cancer you know what i'm
saying
um they're trying to see my daughter now
as you guys if you've been paying
attention
i have two cribs you know what i'm
saying i live in l.a and then i live in
nevada
in nevada i'm looking you know i'm
saying within my birthday month which is
audience to officially have you know i'm
staying in the house where i want it at
and everything um that's why i exactly
like the place of the bible to see like
you know i mess with the area in which i
do i
absolutely love it here you know what
i'm saying just like you know i have an
amazing beautiful girlfriend
um you know that has a lot of people
don't realize that it's literally
kept insane same girl okay
that was dream but this one's his ex but
it's also his baby mama
but he's entirely the current girlfriend
the current girlfriend is dread they're
together and
they're they both be on his own trey i
just want to make sure is that
yeah yeah that's draya okay
does janet only has the mob chad does
jenna have custody
did you have custody
toxic toxicity you know what i'm saying
and here's the thing guys flight
you got to take some responsibility yeah
she's toxic she's crazy
you have money go to court
go to court dude um you know and i
honestly like
have definitely been able to enjoy life
despite that being toxic but now
it got to a point where none of her
bitter stuff even with her like because
when i get to see my daughter like i can
honestly say at most i'm seeing her like
two three times a month i've been
fighting i've been fighting i've been
fighting i've been fighting
you know what i'm saying to see her more
times you know what i'm saying um
i always put and make time you know what
i'm saying for my daughter which is
literally like
no an easy priority obviously you know
what i'm saying my flesh and blood
usually when i'm back and forth l.a and
nevada i'll either be in la for a week
they go to nevada for me or i'll be in
l.a for two weeks and then come back to
nepal for two weeks you know what i'm
saying and vice versa you know what i'm
saying so it's plenty enough time
you know i'm saying where you know mind
you lana has nothing you know what i'm
saying she grew up with everything given
to her she doesn't have no drive no
hustle
nothing she's literally had no job since
honestly i feel like since she's
like like i met her or whatever back in
2018 there's so many girls who just like
don't want to work
they're baffled you know what i'm saying
i mean that's what the power of flight
does not to be cocky but [ __ ] [ __ ]
but like she's literally has no job i
don't know what she does to get money
you know what i'm saying one thing i
will not take away from everything from
this video um it's still you know what
i'm saying like i obviously uh 100
like despise everything still going to
court whatever i'm not taking away from
the fact that she is a great mother
despite her being a hater being my
being a hater being a bitter being she's
a great mother i'm going to say that
right now on this we get that way she's
a great mother she nurtures
my daughter very very well um so there's
definitely no um size of saying that you
know i don't want people to turn around
and say like that she neglects her this
and that she takes very good care of my
daughter
um you know the normal problem is that
she literally dangles it like a string
on when i can see my daughter you know
what i'm saying like i'm really a strong
dude like i literally know plenty of
dudes that break down crying every day
or like do some [ __ ] that can risk their
freedom or just like go around so angry
you know what i'm saying or just have
low energy because they can't see
you know what i'm saying their loved one
or daughter or you know saying or
something whoever they have and all
fathers can relate to this man
and i'm a human i just have the same
question why haven't you gone to court
if she doesn't have money and you do
you're gonna get
you're gonna annihilate at the end of
the day like i feel like it's just
getting to a point
where it's just like enough is enough
like it's just so much kept in she does
you know
she does a lot of bitter things like
let's say if she sees like me and my
girlfriend
you know i'm saying like living life
doing things on a date or whatever like
for example these are examples
with their flat border looking ass i
might want to be cloned go to court bye
you mash your shit's on you you're a 20
year old
what what i have the same reaction that
actually happened you know i'm saying
plenty of receipts in this video and all
you know what i'm saying there's no
mercy you know i'm saying you know
bully's got to get bullied back you know
what i'm saying she's been
mad i don't want us
ugly lunch lady looking cell
i'm bad as a f and you know it she
looking
like a border mexican bed
i'm gonna be honest i think the baby
mama looks better than the girlfriend
i'm just kidding
i'm gonna be honest here i but i
genuinely think they're both pretty um
literally like you know and it's ironic
because she never will talk to any other
person like this at all you know what
i'm saying she's from the suburbs you
know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying she's from the
suburbs she would never talk to nobody
from the hood of cali like all the hoods
in cali like you know what i'm saying
shout out to y'all they would she would
never ever go up and talk wild you know
what i'm saying like the way she does
with me she uses me like a punching bag
you know what i'm saying
you know she literally bitter bitter
bitter bitter after bitterness so yeah
you know what i'm saying like i've been
trying to i've been trying to keep
myself contained man because that's the
number one thing that gets under my skin
is her barely letting me be able to see
my daughter um the
the biggest number one fact is because
she's better that i'm in another
relationship
she's mad to go back what happened
oh my god i didn't even see that
matt i want ugly ass lunch lady-looking
self
i'm bad as [ __ ] and you know it she
looking like a
that's [ __ ] up that's really racist
do you see what that says oh
she oh god did i read that earlier not
register what that meant
his baby mama mexican too
i hate i hate doing this cool parents i
do this around the time then that stuff
okay i've been thinking lately on some
low-key type of [ __ ] we should try to
work stuff out on the low for jay in the
future because no doubt
um i really do want my next baby in two
years or whatever
or should we just keep pushing it this
isn't may
i'm good jay we'll be fine co-parents
oh no that was able you know what she
did and [ __ ] that i've said before
and this and that she laughs about
things like oh imagine i'd be imagine
having a
imagine having a beautiful happy
daughter that you can't see
down bad but i'll mine my own beautiful
happy daughter that you can't see that's
[ __ ] up bro that's so [ __ ] up go to
court
that's really [ __ ] up like flight
you've had time to go to court it's
about that time my guy
jorge thank you so much for the tank
imagine having a pretty daughter that
you can't see and then she'll just like
ghost me and it'll just be like two
three days you know what i'm saying and
then like
she's [ __ ] weird
you know what i'm saying i go off on her
every single time and everything
she continues to play victim she
continues to talk to her family and make
it seem like i'm i'm the problem
um she's done numerous things like lie
to her family lies where her brother lie
to her step brother lie to her sister
a lot of plenty of other family members
you know what i'm saying that
i have like put hands on her when i
never did you know i said i told you
that story when i'm
in my statute video she tried to grab my
phone and she grabbed my phone i tried
it she grabbed my phone
and she threw it off the stair level
where my l.a apartment is at she do it
off that stair level
and i'm saying lucky you didn't crack i
already said that in a sad truth video
um but trust me guys there's so much tea
in this just get your snacks and just
get you know prepared because like i
said
stop this is like it doesn't even seem
real i'm laughing i'm not [ __ ] making
fun
you know i can't obviously be around
there because you know
they sent me through the months like
threatening
you're gonna have to see me
you know what i'm saying and they were
you know they've been confused i think i
cut out an
important part i don't know who's
sending him these messages this just
from like her fans
wait is this her i think she's sending
people yeah yeah
why would her friends do this oh this is
her friends
bro layla she's gonna send her friends
out too
she's crazy what the [ __ ]
it's just like they're both crazy look
you know hold up pause pause pause bro
why am i literally just noticing like
looking at these messages too like why
is atlanta in like her entire family
high key racist bro
you know what i'm saying like they
hockey some caring racist fam
how the hell first of all you gonna tell
me like
and dis my like on fanbase and talk
about like who is what and who is who
bro like everybody all shapes and signs
is allowed to [ __ ] with ftc bro so how
are you gonna sit up here
when somebody's a good liar they can
make it seem like somebody's this of a
person like i mean i guess like you're
just being family and defending but it's
just like i've told them multiple
multiple times i tried to be cordial do
a six months forward shot am i allowed
to do that if i could do that we're
doing that bro
am i allowed to do that [ __ ] with them
they're just not going to buy it you
know what i'm saying they defend that
you know what i'm saying they defend
lana's side and i mean his family like
obviously they're not going to sit there
and defend something from florida you
know what i'm saying like who the [ __ ]
is
you know he's like okay boom so you know
mind you it's never a situation where
let's say people are gonna be like okay
flight like
isn't like your girlfriend you know what
i'm saying like with you you know what
i'm saying like
i never like give her like an
opportunity to even be around my dog
i literally have told her that is every
time my daughter's been with me it's
literally just me like mind you
by the way you know what i'm saying like
and i don't give a [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying like
leonard literally like bro continues
like i said like i don't care like i
said because i know my own thing she
continues to run through dudes and dudes
that's not my biggest problem my problem
is that she brings my daughter around
these dudes around all types of energy
you don't know what these dudes provide
that's right yeah i agree that's that's
completely wrong you know what i'm
saying like like i said
i don't care what she does she can be a
[ __ ] that she was born to be and do her
thing
i'm saying that like how are you gonna
like prevent me from seeing my own flesh
and blood when it's literally just me i
can see if like you don't like my you
know what i'm saying girlfriend this and
that boom
okay focus on the child like she doesn't
ever let me you know what i'm saying be
a father she just like leaves me out
that's the number one thing that she um
that's been since my daughter's been
born she barely left me serious it's
like trying to find a cure for aids
it's like trying to find a cure for
cancer you know i'm saying [ __ ] both of
those diseases you know what i'm saying
and also she has it to a point where she
sometimes extorts me you know what i'm
saying to like see my girl like she
literally uses my daughter as a pawn
yeah
like every single like time that she
gets the opportunity now with us not
being you know what i'm saying on you
know
court document papers you know as a man
you know i'm gonna
you know take care first of all you know
what i'm saying of my daughter now since
my daughter's been born
and a lot of people i feel like they're
like you want to smack me in the back of
my head through the screen
i don't mind if you probably do bro but
it's just me being a caring person me
wanting to you know not only to see like
you know somebody have
you know a good life and great life you
know what i'm saying when when it comes
to just you know
having the kid and just i just wanted to
be comfortable basically so we made an
agreement literally like
two times a month every two weeks i'd
give it twenty five hundred so you do
the max two twenty five hundred times
twenty five
five hundred that's like three four
thousand i think
you feel me like you're getting more
than people that spend a decade in
college you feel me you know what i'm
saying getting from literally
you know i don't wanna stay doing
nothing because was college expensive
yeah maybe like five kids of western
gold like food and stuff
and like your dorm okay
and this is it's interesting people's
world views because he's saying oh
like he he makes it seem like he's so
out of control of this situation but
why haven't you gone to court i keep
saying the same thing
he doesn't need like he's selfishly
making this video
bringing this drama to the internet to
make himself look good to get his
followers
on his side to get that maybe like
comfort you know of knowing his fans
like know him whatever
i get that i've been there i understand
that but here's my problem
one it's not about you it's about your
daughter and
two you could go to court and get it
legally mandated where she has to give
you your kid a certain amount of times
per month because i'm sorry seeing your
dad
once or twice a month that's not
acceptable that's not okay
that's wrong that's absolutely wrong you
should have a lawyer yesterday
15 grand like hey do we know should i
see here on tuesday wednesday
you know what i'm saying friday tuesday
wednesday and saturday it's like stuff
whenever i'm out in the leg and i'm
saying it's like hell it's like hell you
know what i'm saying like trying to like
get to see her and then when i finally
budge
and i get to see her i see her for no
more than like an hour and a half two
hours you know what i'm saying she'll
say things like
uh oh um send me the child support money
or send me my payment deposit you should
say like slip that [ __ ] like that send
me that stuff three days early i need to
see your daughter you know what i'm
saying and me being a nice person i am
just being a bigger man like i've
literally done that stuff like a couple
times like bro like i want to see my
daughter so bad like my daughter's
literally so beautiful so cute she's so
healthy
what's up and just like she literally
like she makes me happy just looking at
her
you know what i'm saying i never thought
that you know what i'm saying like you
don't have a kid would just do that and
have an effect on you you know what i'm
saying and it's just like for you to
just like literally use
another kid that can't even see their
abcs right like as a pawn and
an extortion you know i'm saying just to
get your upper hand because you're
bitter i want to be with you
you know what i'm saying like it's
something and god watches all that you
know i'm saying god sees all that stuff
you know what i'm saying and shout out
to like you know for one you know my
girlfriend for keeping me sane through
this she's literally been trying to do
any and everything you know i'm saying
i'm gonna continue to go over
hey you know like i said bro whether we
whether we don't know what happens
between flight andrea behind
you know closed doors and stuff so you
know on the internet because that one
video might look like he was
you know weird or not weird but you know
[ __ ] up and taking it back but we
don't know she could be actually a
really good girlfriend to him so
mad for watching okay
keep the same energy now you're gonna be
mad for a watch me and good luck with
your corvette
good luck with your course hey guys just
in case you guys didn't catch on but if
you guys are seeing some android texting
or like dream message texting and then
going cycling back to the iphone it's
because atlanta and like her fam
sometimes will text me from like fake
numbers or like iphone messaging apps
and i don't want to dispose of numbers
just in case
you know what i'm saying it's gonna come
back broken like continues to like put
that over my masculine
miser a miserable bitter can't wait to
see god give you the karma
i hope you don't oh my gosh hey look
there's a little bitter [ __ ] can't wait
to see god
jesus i'm gonna do something do
something to the whip
um you know what i'm saying just
continuous amounts of threats and
threats and threats bro you know what
i'm saying reminds you guys like
she literally will never talk like to
this to any of the girls or anybody else
that
is about that life you know what i'm
saying like this is a suburb valley cali
girl bro she's a diver
like been in any struggle she never will
talk to anybody like this you know what
i'm saying so
the fact that she talks to somebody
that's you know because you know i'm
civilian you feel like i'm a regular
not you have a regular i'm a civilian
i'm a citizen in this bit you know what
i'm saying i'm not about that life you
know what i'm saying so for you to
continue like you know what i'm saying
when i mean threats as well like she
continues to just like say [ __ ] like oh
like i can't wait to see you get jumped
or whatever like my family
like all the time like i should not be
like that like in l.a because she's made
certain [ __ ] uncomfortable you know what
i'm saying for me to just like you know
move and like
i've had certain times where i've had a
bodyguard and stuff like that but like
for the most part like i'm a solo
[ __ ] bro like i don't like to just roll
you know what i'm saying just like with
you know people but like it's gotten to
a point where
unfortunately like outside of me like if
i go to a van or i'm at a show and i
have a bodyguard you feel me like i'm
probably here i don't have adhd
you know i really don't like a bodyguard
bro because you know what i'm saying i
can't risk my freedom
over a girl you feel me that is trying
to be bitter
i dropped my daughter off with me and
enjoyed yourself you feel me but you
know what i'm saying she chose it nor me
and chose to spend the day you know
saying that doing that they would do
you so i would talk like be like um chaz
is the second video right here you know
what i'm saying for you know like a flu
shot
ftc all right so i 100 apologize both of
my camera batteries died out and i
didn't want to like wait too long to
charge so i lose my train of thought and
just lose the flow from the whole video
but yes man like she'll literally like
try any and every type
a chance to like just grab my like body
parts you know saying trying to get me
turned on and i just literally like be
like bro like stop [ __ ] touching me
there was one time like i was about to
say the second to last time that i had
seen my daughter
um she did that [ __ ] when i went to go
take my daughter to the doctors um for
her shots
and when we came home and she came to uh
you know i'm saying like you know drop
daughter
why are you just like exposing
everything like why is he just telling
everyone
their business because like look what
she's telling him and [ __ ] like he's
just trying to maybe
maybe he could use this thank you i
don't know
thank you i have been trying i've been
saying this the whole video
often you know let me do my thing cause
we both took her you know what i'm
saying uh to the hospital you know i'm
saying to get her shots
and everything like that and then she's
gonna go drop the daughter back off home
and let me be with her um she continues
she did that same exact thing you know
when i got into the crib like and i feel
so bad you know saying because my
daughter was right there you know what
i'm saying
one second what
chad's gotten off on her you know i'm
saying she tried to like like atlanta
she tried to play victim and start
crying
and then here comes more of the threats
imagine you know what i'm saying like
imagine what i'm thinking too like when
she's doing this like she's literally
like saying like
hey six months bro i can't take anymore
it's actually really [ __ ] annoying
bro
i have to do six months and i have to
bro like they're actually weirdos bro
they're little weirdos bro
myself you know what i'm saying that i
shouldn't have to be you know what i'm
saying especially in like one of the top
richest states you know i'm saying
living bro i didn't come to la to be
more dangerous bro you know what i'm
saying but actually you have to stay
dangerous you know what i'm saying
you know um with just life in general
you know you never get too comfortable
that's when they come for you and that's
the quote of the day you know what i'm
saying
but yeah man like literally okay i'm
gonna tell you something
guys my dad's the most successful person
i know
genuinely genuinely
he's super successful he came from like
from nothing right his family had 12
siblings they were not well off the more
successful he got
because he didn't involve himself with
those type of people
and that type of drama people didn't
come for him they might have talked [ __ ]
but he didn't have to stay dangerous but
we live in a giant man [ __ ] like
and i guarantee my dad makes more money
than any of these people uh sexy assault
you choose you choose who you associate
yourself with these are the choices you
make
sorry you messed with her for six months
you made that choice
on top of that you have not gone to
court
i keep saying the same thing i'm sorry
that is such thing as a woman doing that
to the man she'll try to like you know
what i'm saying flirt with me all types
of time
she sends me flirty messages uh she
tries to send me like explicit pictures
and all that type of stuff i would show
them for the stream
but we're not gonna get age restricted
baby you know what i'm saying like
karma is going to come to you and i'm
big chilling because guess what even if
she does it to wear like when we deal
with this course stuff and i barely be
able to see my daughter bro i know the
good and solid [ __ ] that i am by the
time like i said my daughter's old
enough to understand everything you know
18 years old bro she's just going to
turn her back in the mother bro like i
don't know why you moms out there insist
on trying to keep your uh
your the child away from the father
they're just going to reason that's
wrong
it's wrong to trash talk the mother of
your kids to your kids
especially at 10 years old that's wrong
that's so wrong
she broke every friend that i've had
that literally had that same scenario
you know what i'm saying not my snare
because i'm looking at one of a kind
like you know what i'm saying that's
doing what i'm doing but just a general
fact of a bitter baby mama you know what
i'm saying like it's affected them every
single time it's affected every single
one of them now i stated like um when i
have made them feel like you're not
gonna like my daughter and everything
that i won't be you know spamming this
with my kid and everything like that
because like i'm not trying to put her
face like out there like that it just
make her feel like you know
you know that she's like a you know
money machine for views that's just
never the case but i do have the right
as someone that
a kid that came out of someone's you
know i'm saying sperm sack that i
produced the kid too like this is my kid
too
you know what i'm saying like i helped
create the kids who you feel me so
i always say that like look i'm not
gonna like you know you spamming videos
with my you know saying my daughter but
at the same time what's wrong with that
you know
um baby yeah okay give me like
10 more minutes i'm saying like she
doesn't let me do it i feel a little
uncomfortable with whatever is going on
in the corner
but any type of videos like matter of
fact the most shadiest thing
you guys probably can't believe that she
doesn't bro like every daughter video
that i had or anything discussing that
bro she literally i don't even know how
youtube allows this to happen like she
said and then here's the screenshots of
it she sent fake copyright strikes
you know what i'm saying she said like
fake like strikes or like privacy
whatever
you know i'm saying this and that you
know i'm saying all because i don't want
to be with you
literally that's literally a reason like
all because like i'm not in a
relationship with uh you know
because she can't pull me back and she
thought that having a kid was gonna make
me stay and come back
you know what i'm saying um she fake um
uh privacy complaints or copyright you
know i'm saying the video
oh my god the message youtube gives you
a certain amount of time to fix it you
know and obviously i couldn't really fix
it because she put in a fake thing to
make it seem like
what it wasn't so i had to take it down
you know what i'm saying i don't care
about the you know i'm saying the view
is lost but i can care less about that i
care the fact i can't
be a father i can't like express how
happy i am to have a daughter
um mind you you know what i'm saying she
literally actually did a face reveal the
other day no i'm saying i've been trying
to do i don't see what the problem would
have been with that you know saying but
then again
it goes back to her being bitter um so
yes you guys like i don't know what you
got to say that so imagine somebody
trying to extort you all the time
and just be a gold digger and just be
that cool boom okay like i already know
what what
what got yourself into at this point you
know i'm saying gold digger just want
money boom
but how you gonna ask for that type of
money first of all i've never given a
20k ever ever ever
ever ever and i haven't you know what
i'm saying that's too much you know what
i'm saying but imagine you let's you
know by telling y'all i give her like 25
i used to i haven't did it like honestly
like the last two months because she got
greedy and i also found out um and i'm
gonna tell you in a second
um but anyways you know imagine you
being that greed for money and then when
i'm trying to
get the money you're like trying to take
down the moneymaker you feel me like
you're taking down
you're trying to destroy the bag that's
just helping jay for the future
like do you want to be sad and broke
like or it's just like i don't
understand that you know what i'm saying
so
i don't know anybody that knows about
mental health if y'all can just help me
figure that out she's affected my mental
health so bad i just don't care about
you know
making her not cover her name you know
what i'm saying because i don't even
know first of all how she hasn't
literally just been super super canceled
bro
have you guys been sleeping on a rock
bro like have you all found out that
she's a pedophile she's a 25 year old
got caught talking to a 16 year old you
know what i'm saying i'm not going to
say who his name is
actually on the internet i'm saying you
guys can find it you know what i'm
saying and figure it out and everything
like that who's the kid but yes
you know what i'm saying dating a 16
year old you know what i'm saying um
that's the same person by the way that
um she left pregnant while she was
pregnant
you know what i'm saying and this and
that and at the same time trying to do
all these like toxic things like you
can't be toxic and being a [ __ ] like
that if you are johnson
do that like even just mess with other
dudes boom i already been not here but
why are you not letting me be happy you
know what i'm saying but you can do
yourself really it looks like you're not
happy you're miserable you're mad i
can't have you so you're trying to do
that that's
crazy under my skin and when that
doesn't work you know i'm saying she
started resorting to now
she's doing recently she's messaging my
girlfriend 445 no
deleting or cropping out certain parts
of messages you know what i'm saying
that's like what it looks like even like
you know when my daughter's here
she drops her off she always says like
just kind of saying disrespectful things
you know i'm saying towards my
girlfriend you know i'm saying mind you
i've never said anything about any other
dudes you know what i'm saying i know
each and every single one of them you
know what i'm saying that she comes
across
she's jealous because she tries to send
them to me lagging i think
is this the laggy are we good we good
all right cool
fake numbers you know what i'm saying
she tends to she makes she makes eye
message numbers fake account numbers and
all that stuff and sends them to me and
be you know just this is it's just
sickening bro
you know what i'm saying this is very
sickening um yeah she's resorting to try
messaging my girlfriend and try to make
it seem like i'm doing things behind her
back
you know i'm saying that was just like
honestly like the last row you know what
i'm saying like everything else before
and i was like honestly being a real
[ __ ] and keeping [ __ ] into what i
possibly can
you know what i'm saying um but it's
just it just hasn't you know what i'm
saying been been been worked wow like
you really boss up and blow it up like
that like she had to say leave like text
me like some random like out of town she
was just like oh [ __ ]
okay get your coins you need it after
that ugly ass corvette
thought that [ __ ] was going to do
something to your ass
you wish you could have wrote in it
laughing bought it off the lot 120k
no payments and it's still ugly you
could never
hate her should have got a lambo okay
what you can't get a lamb
you don't have a lambo gotta show some
coins you need after that ugly ass
corvette
okay but this is he shouldn't be arguing
with her don't respond
you like the drama because you're
responding
what the [ __ ] like first of all she's
been driving the same car since i met
her in 2018 whatever
i'm saying i was driving a little nissan
you know saying that i was driving at
that time as [ __ ] doesn't hurt you that
i upgraded three rips whips and i'm
saying during the time the new mercedes
you know what i'm saying the cls and you
got the g wagon and you got the
corporate when you see me talk to g
wagon you know what i'm saying she was
like damn okay he blowed up but when she
seen me talk that 20 21
versus she almost lost it i promised
y'all she almost lost it you know what
i'm saying she knew she was wrong
because she came back you know i'm
saying the next like week after she
probably seen you know i'm saying shout
out to like little baby you know what
i'm saying a little dirt when she seen
them
bro first of all this shot is way better
everyone's from w chat this chat is
actually nice as [ __ ]
i'm saying pushing the corvette that is
a millionaire there's nothing wrong by
the way without having any type of car
with any money you've got that's number
one for that honestly don't go out and
try to impress people
i go out to get in things that make me
happy and impress me you know what i'm
saying so um yeah you know so she ended
up apologizing
like the next week after that and then
she tried to side that and flirt with me
and be like oh you need to give me a
ride one day let's go out to malibu
after she said all that stuff
you know and like obviously i continue
to reject her and do that type of stuff
man
um you know she continues to you know
just do better you know stuff you know
every time when i reject her basically
from her trying to pull me back inside
my side or just try to get people
um um coming out of the club
imagine your own baby daddy coming out
of the closet just make it different
it's just
bro what so i just thinking like oh like
she's saying she's going on twitch
basically trying to say that i'm like
okay
oh my god i'm so tired
okay unpopular opinion he's just as
toxic
as she is you are what you attract
um oh my god i've almost spent two hours
watching this stuff
but yeah i think a lot of times they
want to blame it on the girl
or the guy but if you're constantly in
the same type of relationship
like you kind of have to look in the
mirror and ask yourself why do i keep
ending up in this situation
um let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or disagree don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification
bell while you're at it um and follow my
instagram it's just pearly things with
the z
i'm trying to hit 10 000 followers on
instagram so that'd be cool
i will talk to you guys next time